[Musique]
place seigneur fais de moi la plus
grande star que le monde est jamais
connu pour que je puisse partir loin
très loin de cet endroit
tu sais prendre soin de ta famille quand
les temps sont durs c'est admirable la
pure vérité c'est que tu n'auras qu'une
seule vie si seulement elle pouvait
mourir
pardon
rien
je veux être spécial je veux danser à
l'écran comme les jolies filles dans les
films
[Musique]
je ne pourrai pas te laisser quitter
cette ferme à nouveau
[Musique]
j'ai peur qu'il y ait quelque chose qui
aille vraiment pas chez moi il paraît
qu'il ne prendront peut-être qu'une
seule fille par ville suivante
on recherche quelqu'un avec un petit
quelque chose en plus il faut que ce
soit moi
que penses-tu d'un film que personne
d'autre n'a vu
ça finira par la lettre
je sais ce que j'ai fait
une mauvaise chose
monstrueuses mortelles
[Applaudissements]
possibles
en vérité je suis pas vraiment une bonne
personne
[Musique]